este es uno de varios actos marchas y
protestas que tienen lugar este Primero
de Mayo aquí en Buenos Aires y también
en otros lugares de Argentina pero no es
un Primero de Mayo de festejo de
celebración porque hay mucho enojo en el
sector trabajador en Argentina no por
falta de empleo porque el desempleo es
relativamente bajo para la historia del
país pero sí por la baja calidad del
empleo y sobre todo el ingreso hay una
alta informalidad que está por encima
del 30% y también se ha visto muy
comprometida la capacidad de compra del
salario y del ingreso en estos últimos
años sobre todo por un efecto de una
alta inflación que ya está por encima
del 100% anual muchas de estas personas
y estos movimientos consideran que uno
de los responsables es el acuerdo con el
fondo monetario internacional que en
cierta forma ata de Manos al gobierno
para poder tomar políticas que asistan a
los trabajadores y decía al principio
que son muchos los actos que tienen
lugar en este Primero de Mayo y eso es
Porque además el sector trabajador está
muy fragmentado la representación está
muy fragmentada en Argentina de hecho la
central más grande de los trabajadores
la confederación general del trabajo no
tiene un acto este Primero de Mayo sino
que lo hará el 2 de mayo no en la calle
sino en un club en un espacio cerrado